[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se trouve ici sur la place gibert
coudane donc à saclay sur le campus où
un site archéologique d'une maison qui a
été construite au deuxième siècle
troisième siècle à l'époque gallo
romaine a été réalisée donc et on voit
ici l'ensemble des vestiges qui
représente en fait la base de la maison
c'est à dire que en fait on ne voit pas
la partie supérieure ce que l'on voit
c'est en réalité la partie fondation le
plan est assez clair en fait on se
trouve ici sur la partie avant de la
maison et ensuite les pièces se trouvait
à l'arrière avec deux descentes de cave
qui sont encore extrêmement lisible
lorsque j'ai été consulté pour faire ce
chantier moi ce que j'ai défendu c'est
que enfin tout le monde en était
convaincu mais que d'une certaine
manière il faut remettre à la lumière
ces vestiges pour que
le public les habitants les étudiants
les enseignants etc comprennent la
présence d'un site qui est aussi relaté
l'histoire très très longue et très très
intéressant dans un endroit où il ya de
l'enseignement l'éducation et où
justement cette question temporel est
vraiment présent on a travaillé donc la
consolidation des pierres les pierres
que l'on voit là en fait était aussi pas
mal des assemblées en fait il fallait
remettre dumortier entre les pierres ce
qu'on fait progressivement d'un mortier
qui est aussi un mortier de chaux donc
très naturel si vous voulez et qui en
respectant le format qui avait été bien
relevé par les archéologues qui eux
mêmes d'ailleurs sur le site on trouvait
aussi des poteries enfin différents
éléments qui sont un peu la trace de la
vie dans cette maison c'est un site qui
sera en fait pas accessibles sans
accompagnement
le public pourra rentrer soit sur
demande soit lors de manifestations
particulières des journées du patrimoine
ou autre jour et les archéologues en
fait continue toujours un peu à
travailler
ce sont des bénévoles qui continue à
travailler toujours sur le site
[Musique]